I was a suck up to my parents I don't
think I like spoke to my parents for
like 3 years what well not like in a
meaningful way did your dad beat
you welcome back to another episode of
trash taste I'm Connor and once again
joined by the boys Joey and G do you
have anything but purple t-shirts in
your I just I I've just realized now I
thought you were wearing the trash
t-shir no no you've moved over to Twitch
it's cuz I when I'm when I'm cycling
it's really easy to get like pretty
sweaty so I kind of want to pick the
finished and like most t-shirt like
shirt con is definitely happy of the
fact that we just happened to pick TR
purple as the trash taste color you know
I didn't wear purple much before but now
I just like it yeah so I I Pi the thin T
because you're surrounded by it all the
time yeah maybe like subliminal
messaging like purple purple you like
purple um how you guys been how you guys
been doing good this episode's coming
out the week we record it so that's yeah
so we decided to talk to make another
topco episode most recent you'll see us
yeah and I guess like one of the most
recent topical things that has happened
not just like in the previous like two
weeks but it seems to we keep happening
now is uh YouTubers ruining Japan that
is not us hey we we start we we started
we actually actually no let's let's
let's give out let's give our shout out
to the OG Logan Paul for starting off
the
trends such a good job that Chris had to
go on national TV and uh coin the iconic
a YouTuber to apologize and show that
YouTube is a kind of normal he's a TR
yeah where is Chris now where we need
him most on on National Television to
tell everyone that YouTubers aren't bad
yeah uh but yeah so yeah that's been a
big thing obviously there's the the
famous one with Johnny SM which we
didn't talk about and I didn't talk
about at all and I think most of us
didn't because we didn't want to give
him more attention while he was still
alive it seemed like he kind of thrived
off getting attention onck and causing
all these like terrible kind of oh trust
me I would have made 10c Channel videos
on him but then I thought to myself no
this is exactly what he wants and I
guess this exactly what he wants he was
fueling off it and then now obviously
he's been arrested and twice twice yeah
because Japan has this I mean it's
actually kind of terrifying it's a
really weird system uh they can hold you
for 28 days is it maybe correct 28 or 24
can't remember honey uh and then before
they have to charge you anything
obviously in in most Western countries
the UK and us I think it's 24 or 48
hours I think it's 48 before they have
to charge you with anything so it's it's
kind of terrifying that they can like in
Japan they can they can hold you for 28
days they can ruin your life cuz you
know you don't if you don't show up to
work you can't talk to anyone you can't
contact anyone except your lawyer um uh
and so you're in the system and then
they have this amazing thing that they
can do which I don't know how they're
allowed to do this this is insane to me
if you don't get charged in that period
they can just charge you with something
else the moment that period is up which
is what they're doing right now yeah
which
I listen it's a it's a some some people
Karma hits very get well for but
sometimes you're like man I wish the
system wasn't [__] though as well but
you're like damn but it is nice to see
when the [__] system is kind of used
in a in a kind of useful way to Target
someone who's just a SC Scourge on the
earth so so if you don't know who Johnny
SMY is if you are not in tune with I
guess the streamer culture uh good on
you but touch yeah he was a streamer
that blew up on Kick a while ago well he
yeah yeah kick banned from the other
platforms I believe yeah I I believe he
got banned from the other platforms and
he made a name for himself by basically
going out to the streets of Japan and uh
to put it simply harassing people just
straight up just straight up if if you'd
heard about one of those guys who are
like just shouting Hiroshima and
Nagasaki in the middle of a [__]
train oh no I just remember I did make a
video on that first incident you the
first guy you did oh the first one where
he was on the train and he was blasting
music and then my God like and then he
went up to a random just innocent salary
man in Japan and was just like Hiroshima
Nagasaki do you remember it we'll do it
again I [__] tell you and I'm like
what do you have like government
connections like what how what where is
this confidence coming from sad thing
about that guy is everyone was like wow
I'm sure he's just a tourist like no
he's been living here eight years yeah
and then didn't speak any Japanese and
then also um I guess was like a
40-year-old man essentially he was no no
no that's a different one what yeah yeah
yeah that's a different one you were
talking about the other the guy who's
like blasting SRX
why so many of so that was the first one
I did I didn't mention him by name and
I'm still not going to cuz he deserves
no attention but then I actually did do
the first Johnny Somalian then where he
talked about the Hiroshima Nagasaki [__]
well that was bad cuz like that
immediately made news in Japan yeah yeah
and uh naturally yeah that one was that
one was interesting that was where uh
listen uh Japanese people online if you
if you if you give them a reason to
think that they can say what they want
to say holy [__] did they say some he
[__] the comments I was seeing were
[__] awful yeah if you thought if you
thought fourchan was bad you've never
been on two CH I I've never seen such I
mean I've been I've seen a western thing
holy [__] the open racism was crazy on
the J side uh cuz they just felt
justified in being racist in a way you
know that's the you know that's the one
reason when I decided to move to Japan I
didn't make a Japan like Japanese
channel oh okay well I was like cuz I
used to be on two Chan when I was in
high school cuz I was dumb as [__] and I
had too much time on my hands and I saw
my God it made it made the new grounds
forums look like a playground like it
was it was bad and I was like well if I
say anything bad they're going to take
one look at this face and they go stupid
guy Jin probably the teest thing they'll
say and then they'll just cancel me off
the face of the Earth over nothing
probably but this one was uh definitely
this whole jie Sali thing and all the
other ones he was involving he was
inciting action and VI Ence there was
been cent of plenty of incidents where
you know he just like get punched by
random people on the streets I think
Australian dude who knocked out his
friend and then him which was which was
great he's doing the Aussies crd to see
and you know like this is coming
straight out of just finishing Vinland
Saga season to where you're like I have
no enemies and you're like wait though
violence
actually I don't conf it's it's that
moment where you're like so I don't
condone violence but but it is kind of
uh expected when you do like yeah he
probably watched V Saga and was like I
have no enemies and he was just
like I mean it's easy
to feel no ill will towards people until
there's someone like that in front of
you or you're like actually I I do hate
some people I think some people suck
some people deserve a punch in the face
you know and so obviously he kept
pushing it uh TR was just doing bun of
crimes on camera and then got arrested
and that was cool and then um recently
there was um so the the thought process
I think currently with um Jal I think
they are going to charge him with
something obviously Japan has I think
again this is all like I think I know
this but I'm not 100% sure if you are a
foreigner or foreign National in Japan
and you get charged with over one year
of a crime you are automatically
deported so you if you get over a year
sentence they're just instead of serving
in Japan why would the [__] would they
want to deal with you they just send you
out if it's less than a year I think you
serve it in Japan yeah and I think he
got arrested because he Knuck into a
construction site trespassing was the
first one the second one was and he was
harassing the war it was being a
nuisance in business which is is super
vague and I feel like any of us could be
like if you go in anywhere with a camera
you could be arrested of that it's kind
of a very it's a little it's I will
admit on the the Japanese side they are
they are grasping at straws to keep this
man in jail and it's I mean for this
scenario like oh this is great but also
it's kind of scary at the same time that
you're like if you just piss off the
wrong govern government person you could
just be in jail for whatever [__]
reason yeah I mean it's it's scary but
at the same time it's it it was kind of
like you know this was this is the bare
definition of [__] around and find out
he he was uh [__] around as much as
he possibly could uh and he found out
and I the thing that worries me is that
this will set the wrong kind of like
expectations and precedent because I saw
like it's it's rare that a western kind
like content creator makes news in the
Japanese feere he's even like for a good
reason yeah yeah yeah exactly well
another another streamer was um in in
jail for 30 days but wasn't charged with
anything because they were trespassing
uh I think I don't know if they were
streaming but they were at the Fukushima
nuclear exclusion Zone oh yes yeah I
remember this um but that was that that
didn't get nearly as much backlash as
this did which is kind of crazy in a in
a weird way cuz it's why do you think
that is I just think it's the nuisance
he was just he was such an easy person
to hate the Japanese or it was the
Japanese public just being like don't
worry the radiation will get him
eventually we don't have to do it so we
don't have
to so we don't have to do anything no
cuz they're doing so nature is taking
its C wait okay that's that's a that's
an insult to everyone joer okay okay if
if if I'm just joking look look look I
like I I I know why okay because like
trespassing it's just like eh doesn't
really affect to me you see a clip of
someone being loud on the train and I
think Japanese people are like we found
number that is very visceral for
Japanese people it goes It goes against
everything the Japanese have build on
and then he starts shouting out
Hiroshima and Nagasaki being a public
nuisance you know this like he is the
complete antithesis of what [__] like
Japan as a society accept especially in
public you know absolutely yeah um uh
yeah uh it'll be interesting to see how
it all plays out yeah because we he had
like this the other YouTuber I don't
know if you saw this about a guy who
went around Japan and he was like the
YouTuber the YouTube video I believe was
like how I traveled around Japan for
free yep most recent one yeah yeah yeah
okay first of all though this guy's
YouTube channel I don't want to name it
but he has this one thumbnail where it's
like I survived the poorest place on
Earth and it's just like a white dude
surrounded by like 20 black kids and
it's like what is this you are you are a
human plague you are you are
insufferable you are so [__] useless
you you provide less to humanity than
the Barnacles on shipping boats you are
such a useless person that's one of
those thumbnails I just wish you were
joking about you know like it's so
[__] up that like it's it's insane you
didn't make that up you know yeah I the
like the zero level of awareness as a
human being to upload that and be like
I'm okay with this blows my mind but
yeah so he he he did uh it was like 11
days I think or something in the video
like a we he did what we did with uh our
video which is traveling from like the
most southern point of Japan to the most
northern Point ofely faked 90% of it cuz
he sneaks getting on the bullet train
and if you ever been on a bullet train
you can't do that there's absolutely no
shot he's pulling that off there's
there's you might be able to maybe get
through the gate but it would be so
tough like it's not the New York subway
you can't just like jump the gate
willing it is like there are at least
like in most like train stations where
you can get the shin g s there's at
least like two or three dudes who are
there making sure you get on yeah
there's one train that you don't want to
you attempt [__] around with and
trying to pull that [__] on that one you
will 100% get caught it's like trying to
sneak on a plane you know it's like it
just doesn't it doesn't happen it's very
very like tough so I believe he because
even in the video he just happens to
spawn on the train and obviously clearly
fake but one thing he did do is that I
think he he the thing that pissed me off
most about this video is he was just
begging Jeff and people for money when
he was already like making money from
this video and you know people people it
it just sucks to know that a lot of
people here really push themselves and
and work horrible working hours for
really bad pay uh and then some [__]
[__] comes along ask them for like
$20 and then just makes a thousand off
it anyway yeah and I think he definitely
knew that that is like a very like
Japanese thing to do which is like
obviously try and help others need
especially a foreigner in somewhere like
Tokyo right where like there probably a
lot of foreigners come to like these big
cities don't know how to get around and
you know maybe ask you know for like
directions and sometimes maybe even ask
for like some change or whatever right
so like and the the whole idea of like
you know Japanese people like helping
out the Greater Community or helping out
you know others being a Good Samaritan
is very like ingrained in a lot of
Japanese people's mind I most people
will help you out if they you have no
money here and so taking advantage of
that to make a video which you are going
to make money off of anyway also aiding
this person into doing illegal [__] is
just the most scummy [__] thing you
can do yeah and and that obviously made
news in Japan as well was pretty popular
it's just frustrating cuz it's like okay
a lot of goodwi that has been built up
from humans in general it's like oh
let's just squander it we're out here
fighting the [__] good fight making
sure foreigners get a good name for
themselves here and then just a couple
we we go through so much red tape like
fighting tooth and nail fighting for our
lives just to get permission filming in
a place all takes us one person to all
down because like I mean obviously
there's like I I think the thing that
pissed me off right is it's not just
like okay his like Africa video of
course it was like what you what you
would call a dick move right but then
there's there's like there's like I with
the Japan video he's just straight up
breaking laws right I'm yeah I think at
one point in the video he gets on the
bus and does he gets on the bus and just
refuses to pay and then just gets like
uh escorted to the police station or
something like that yeah I think he
thought they were going to drop it cuz
it was ATN in the video
was he had begged someone for 500 600
Yen or something and the fair was 680
Yen so it's about like a 50 4ent
difference and I I think in the video he
thought he was just going to drop it but
that's not it's not how it works you
can't you can't barter and worst maybe
the best case scenario for you the bus
driver might feel so sorry for you is
like a pathetic human cockroach that you
are and he'd give you the ADN to pay
yeah but then it's like even then it's
like like none of these scenarios make
you like a a a human being that is nice
or has any productive uh Tendencies at
all I just think you're just piece of
[__] yeah there isn't a single person
who looked at that and was like oh you
know it's so nice for the bus driver to
like you know spare him that e sense
change you know he's probably living a
hard life no in Japan it's probably like
can't cough it up [__] you yeah pretty
much you're not getting off that's just
you follow by the rules in this country
and if you don't follow by the rules
then you're [__] damn and yeah like
you say it just it it pisses me off when
you get you see someone or you see like
conent creatures kind of like taking
advantage of the Goodwill of just like
one how non-confrontation with Japanese
people are right cuz it's it's like
sometimes you see this in other
countries and you're like oh there is no
way there is no shot some of this
content would be gotten away with if you
film this in America or something that's
I don't feel like if I ever saw a video
like this in the UK I'd be like I'm not
worried if you pull that [__] on someone
I'm sure someone would he'd [__] around
and find out exactly exactly right which
is like why I think a lot of people like
H I don't care
[__] sake what are you doing people are
too nice to you you're human yeah yeah
exactly and you know it's we we've we've
we talk from experience when we've gone
through enough red tape and red Hoops
not you Joe but even to get like visas
to work here uh and trying to instill
something new like a new idea to like
especially like older Japanese people
and it just it it's so annoying when I
see the coverage that these kinds of
like content creators get where there is
so many people out there that are trying
to do things the right way that have
been trying to do things the right way I
mean I can't imagine anyone who's more
pissed about this than Chris is you know
considering how much he's worked to
change the perspective of YouTubers and
content creators in Japan and and that's
the shitty thing right is that like
negative press is always going to just
have a wider attraction you know no
matter where the country or the culture
is and it's definitely the case here
because you know people like Chris and
people like you know us can do the best
things for the country and you know try
and put a positive impact on how
Japanese people especially the older
generation not only just view content
creaters like YouTubers and twitch
streamers but also just like foreigners
living here trying to make an honest
living in general All For You know what
a p on the back you know maybe less [__]
talking behind the scenes meanwhile you
you do one [__] bad thing and you get
your face plased on the front page of
NHK you know do do you think these kind
do you think we're going to continue see
more of these kinds of people oh God I
hope not um but I think so sadly sadly I
think it's going to happen because I
think these two examples especially have
just shown there have been multiple
examples like we've talked about but uh
you get instant views if you do this
[__] in Japan if you did this [__] in
Florida you you you'd be the least
insane person in Florida so like it just
doesn't you don't you don't get anything
out of it so people come to Japan to do
this the scary thing is I think what's
what might happen I really hope this
doesn't happen is not only are there
going to be more people who are doing
this in Japan but there are going to be
more people just doing this in Asia in
general yeah you know cuz I think like
it's already you know kind of an idea as
you said like you know if you did that
in places like the UK or America no one
would bat an ey no one [__] gives a
[__] it's a no one gives a [__] but if
you do it in a country like Asia where
like the way that the culture operates
is different and it's you know [__]
something else for people to see of like
oh you know how would you be able to do
it in Korea or how would you be able to
do it in like Thailand you know I think
uh the concern has has been that they
might try and pass some laws around it
um but I I I don't know it's Japan's
very weird about passing laws they do it
really fast stealthily or they make a
big public 10 years 10 years we might do
it we're thinking about it hey guys what
do you think like and sometimes it just
doesn't happen I I don't I don't know
what they could change um because I it's
if they could do a law that was like
only foreigners are not allowed to do it
they'd do it they
but uh I I think cuz YouTube is is is
really well built up in Japan I think
Japanese YouTubers have been very very
mainstream for a very long time and I've
been I've been making YouTube seem like
a much more kind of um I think YouTube
is yeah and viable platform yeah and I
think in some senses like Japan has
really adopted YouTube culture really
well in its own sense so I don't think
they would be very uh very very hastily
rushing through something Half Baked
think if they were to do something
they'd figure it out cuz I think right
now the way that filming in public works
in Japan is that you can you can film in
public um if it's uh without needing to
blow any one or do anything like that if
it's not for commercial purposes but
obviously if it is it's a lot more
complicated and yeah you have to get
permission and stuff like that it's kind
of it's kind of tough it's it's a really
weird spot right now yeah and like I I
don't know I I think there should be at
least a line drawn in the Sand by the
actual platforms uh if you break a law
and you you film it surely that is like
yeah I mean there's a platform now that
just invited all that in so it's kind of
hard I think you'd think the platforms
would do better I I'm surprised YouTube
they only just took down his video I'm
surprised they didn't do yeah why is it
why is it that like people get a pass
when it's filmed but they don't get a
pass when it's not filmed like how does
that it's so it's so bizarre with with
um YouTube and how they enforce their
rules cuz like sometimes they'll be so
strict on someone and they'll clamp down
and other people they get like a slap on
the wrist obviously with the whole uh
doxing situation of recent oh yeah
that's that was like one where it was
like okay YouTube this is a really weird
stance to take and also took forever um
it it's it's really odd how these
platforms really are very slow to the to
the the ball sometimes they just need to
stop playing favoritism right which is
uh impossible task to ask for it's like
I I think obviously I think the are
doing something kind of right because
I've seen what happens when you go the
kind of like opposite direction and
there when there are clear biases with a
platform like twitch you know where you
try to please a certain amount of
creators and you piss off everyone in
the process you know because I I yeah I
think cuz
sometimes you know on Twitch um and
other I guess twitch more so cuz twitch
is a bit more personal than this less
big creators cuz YouTube has so many
creators YouTube has so many creators
huge right and there are a lot of
creators who bring in there are I think
like tens of thousands of creators who
bring in over a million dollars of
Revenue a year which a lot of people
that bring in a substantial amount of
money right and and none of these people
you want to take away all their ads from
because that's a lot of money that
YouTube loses that YouTube needs because
holy [__] does YouTube cost a lot of
money to run but on Twitch like I've
noticed that like you definitely if
you're a creator that is bigger and you
have a very good track record you
definitely get the benefit of the doubt
with certain things or they'll be like
okay just be careful next time yeah um
because you do you have that track
record and you are a bit more favorable
but
obviously if you it's such a fine thing
to to do that because if you give too
much leeway then a lot of the audience
from other audiences that might see this
might be like what the [__] Conor got
his [__] out why isn't he banned um
that's [__] up I think there's a case
that people were really calling for a
band recently where a streamer was
driving while texting uh and they were
kind of like a they had a very good rap
yeah um and it took a little while for
them to get the ban but I think everyone
unanimously was like they should get a
banned for this that's just dangerous um
and I think if that didn't happen and I
think it only happened because of the
sheer amount of like people being like
you have to give this person a ban there
is an horrible prec the the community
pressure right yeah yeah but I think if
the pressure wasn't there I don't think
it would have happened because it took
like two or three days for the band to
come through if I recall correctly I
mean you know there there's a lot of
instances of like a Creator you know
YouTube twitch or whatever doing
something that is very questionable you
sometimes just straight up you
know yeah caught red-handed and it's not
until it gets enough attention from the
community whether that be on like
Twitter or you know just YouTube in
general to for YouTube to finally be
like oh they did a bad thing oh uh yeah
okay we we'll do what you guys said
thanks thanks for letting us know it
really depends I don't really fully
understand how it works but I I've just
noticed that sometimes you you get you
get a little Goodwill here and there
yeah but it's just how it works right it
reminds me of like that one Tik tocker a
while ago he was like British I believe
who just like filmed himself breaking
and entering into like people's houses
and stealing dogs and just like
literally committing crimes to the point
where he got arrested and like he was in
court and the judge asked him if he was
going to do it again he was like yeah
yeah and they he did yeah and like the
problem is like God is somehow someone
like this who is clearly like not even
like being a dick but just like breaking
laws this is a new level now this is
like someone is breaking the laws of the
country you're in and uh they can get
away with it just because because Tik
Tok walked at and went like yeah but do
you see how many [__] views this gets
though see that that one uh these kids
in America were filming themselves uh
doing hit and runs what and they they
killed a police officer cuz they hit him
on a bicycle oh I heard about that they
filming it and then when they got
arrested they were like Noah it's not
that serious though right oh yeah yeah I
think I think I saw this yeah yeah and
like what and dude I mean like watching
it I was like dude I sometimes I was
like man these old people when they talk
about kids having it good these days I
was like man maybe they're right maybe
they don't maybe they don't get punished
enough God I think I think some some
kids go like their whole life in school
thinking they just can't be punished cuz
like clearly that's what must have
happened some father Behavior how the
[__] did like these kids commit straight
up crimes and think that like they'll
just get a slap on the wrist parents
please beat your
kids you know we need more parents to
beat their children I just like
I just going to say it you need to have
you as as a kid you need to have that
innate fear of the moment when you do
something wrong that that absolute like
cold sweat passes through your body you
know when your parents are about to
murder you and I would do that that [__]
over like dropping a bowl so like we
need to bring this back I don't know if
we stop doing it you need I need to be
straight up scared of doing anything
wrong how that's why I'm that's why I'm
so well behaved I cuz every time I think
about doing something bad I can feel the
glare of my father about to murder me
yeah and that's just like the
environment I was I grew up in and like
that kind of discipline I feel just
parents look I'm not going to teach
parents how to parents I just feel like
such your boom is saying this like I
feel like Boomer but I feel like clearly
feel like I'm right like people must not
be getting disciplined how does this
happen Okay for like just say none of us
are parents here I'm about to [__]
parent someone none of us are parents
here none of us are parents but you know
how we're going to be as
parents so future children watch your
ass my kid does not get to [__] around
like that oh no does anything in school
he his life is ruined abely killing him
I brought him into this world I can
easily take him out I'm taking him of
this world what do you mean you got a
see and you w well behaved look I think
I think the big thing is that just
children just need discipline and you
know that doesn't necessarily mean we
whip out the [__] belt or whatever
that's all back in the [__] 1960s I
can look we get the belt and the
slipper we got to bring it back we got
to overcorrect throw throwing the back
scratcher in there every now and then
dude you know Choose Your Weapon that's
not what we're saying uh but we are
saying that some some kids just need to
learn that there are consequences to
actions I don't know that's what I'm
saying we need like you know Mal on the
middle when they misbehaved so much they
had to go to the military we should do
that we should do
that I would have I would have not I
would have been very well
behaved yeah I mean like Navy Army Air
Force take your pix oh God you're going
to one of them do do you think okay this
going to be a weird question do you do
you think kids need fear yeah 100% okay
okay then then let me ask what what is
the difference between fear and respect
because that's that's a very fine line
you know that's that that's a very fine
line because you can like overshoot and
the kid will just fear you and respect
you but that fear will like overshadow
the respect and then there's the fear
that they will lose your respect and
then that's kind of like that's what I'm
aiming for you know I I want to instance
my kids the fear that they're going to
disappoint me right right right right
right not not so much that they're going
to fear that I'm going to scary cuz I
think that like if you you could raise
the kid the exact same way and I think
sometimes you could just get a little
[__] satanic little [__] who's just
who's just no matter what you would have
done I think he would have just been
absolute human God he came out evil out
I think it just happens I I mean there's
like I mean I think some some oh man I
don't know there's got to be some people
who are just born to be absolute like oh
absolutely evil you have someone I
believe that for sure right am I crazy I
feel like there's you you could like
yeah I feel like there's got to be a
chance of that happening I don't know
okay well then here's the question for
you g like you are in that position
where you are very much like that with
like your dad for evil kid G I'm like
you have no enemies trust trust trust
you have no enemies I think I'd get
impatient I think I I G would G play the
long game the long game he' played a
long game what is the long game
the kid would be a little [__] and God's
like no he'll come around 5 years later
he comes around and it's like oh wow he
knew how did you do it it's like I just
waited okay you must have had that
moment right have okay tell me that that
you've had this moment where your
parents have told you you'll appreciate
this when you're older up to every day
of my life and and then there is that
one thing that you're like [__]
actually actually thank you Mom and Dad
for forcing me to learn TI because I did
appreciate that dude for me every day
since I moved out legit every day since
I moved out it could be small tiny
little things and I'm just like oh now I
get it yeah this is the pain of paying
taxes I get it now oh this is what
cleaning your room is like and your
parents not being there to tell you to
do it you just need to do it because no
one else is going to do it you know just
small little things and it's like yeah
totally when I was a kid and I was
leaving with my parents and my parents
were doing everything for me it's like I
didn't [__] understand it of course I
didn't cuz i' never been thrown into to
that position but now that I am and now
that I'm a fully functioning adult I can
understand like oh okay my parents were
right what a shock and I think it's
because of that that my respect grew for
them even more so than it was already
yeah but like the tough thing as a
parent I I feel like is that you just
have those [__] years when they're
like between the ages of I'd say 14 and
19 where they're like [__] you I know
the best I know everything cuz I know
that's going to happen cuz I thought
that
until I realized in my [__] mid 20s
that I'm like [__] I was a [__]
[__] [__] and I was I was a
dumbass I didn't know anything I think
you just got to you got to instill the
values that you you want them to get and
not push too much cuz also as a teenager
you got to have that space but you also
can't let them go crazy and do hit and
run on Tik Tok see I see I didn't have
that period when I was in high school I
was I was a suck up to my
parents I was I was like if if if a
parents like if there's teachers pets I
was the parents pet like I was like
everything I did I was like I don't want
to disappoint my mom I don't think I
like spoke to my parents for like 3
years what well not like in a meaningful
way really I think I was just like no I
don't I don't know how my parents did it
but like they just gave me that
environment where I was like oh yeah I
can just talk about anything with my
parents well my parents did I think I
was just a little [__] I think I just
didn't want to and I think that I just
need to figure that out myself did your
dad beat
you such a good out
of what this is like this like the arm
chest
psychologist know like I like the color
orange did your dad beat you
yeah real real question no the only the
only thing that uh my Dad did do is that
occasionally if we were up too late he
would come in with the slipper and hit
us on the butt with it oh that's that's
Child's Play what do you mean what did
you get [__] WrestleMania oh dude I I
got full fist what that's too much
that's too much but like my dad was
really okay my dad was really I'm not
saying my dad was violent okay what the
[__] full fist yeah but like he I don't
know he was a [__] like sholing monk
with this [__] cuz like he would he
would like throw the fist like either
like on the shoulder or just like you
know yeah just like like one of those
right but he did it in a way where it
didn't hurt it was just a lot of force
right you know what I mean so like when
you when you when you punch him on the
shoulder like being like stopping a
little [__] like that he would punch it
in a way where it wouldn't like leave
like a mock or anything like it wouldn't
like hurt immediately but but it would
push so bad but but it would but it
would push me back and that force is
what scared me okay for the record I
know my dad watches trash taste dad I
realize you didn't beat me up as a child
okay I know there wasn't any like child
endangerment [__] happening but from
just like that little thing of like
realizing that my dad is like a a
literal force to be reckoned with right
is what instilled that fear in me of
respect and think that's what kind of
disciplined me knowing that like I don't
want to see my dad be like that to me
because that clearly upsets him and I
don't want to see my parents upset you
know so like he kind of did it in a way
which I think it worked for me obviously
cuz I have a lot of respect for my
parents obviously uh but you know
whenever I got into any bad things then
like I would have that fear you never
want to fall into that fallacy of like
it works for me cuz sometimes sometimes
people would turned out like very
well-rounded individuals in spite of
some of the things that happened in
their childhood and I would say that a
lot of the times um you know this is
this is something that a lot of people
figure out is that a lot of the times
you can hold on to scars for things that
you don't even know you hold on to scars
for until you like grow way older and
maybe like talk to a th therapist or
something you're like wait yeah I would
be perpetually scared about that yeah
yeah and and and you're like wait I I I
thought I was a Balan individual until I
started talking to people and I'm like
wait did I turn into this person in
spite of what happened because of what
happen you know so you know you never
want to fall into that fallacy and uh
that's kind of like what that's that's a
hard that's the hard thing of what you
have to try and figure out as you grow
older cuz you what you want to do or at
least my life philosophy is you know as
a kid you're like my parents are the
best my parents are super human they're
perfect and then you realize as you grow
older that hey they were just trying to
be the best person they can be and learn
from their parents and when you realize
that you're going to be that same person
you're going to try and take the good
thing from your parents and try to learn
from the mistakes that made as well
that's kind of like the life cycle of
what I think is being a good parent and
being a good child um because I think
the worst thing you can do is just learn
nothing from your parents and don't try
to improve on them or something I think
is equally bad is that when I've seen so
many people where their parents have
done some kind of [__] up or done
something bad that's [__] them up and
then they kind of like pivot and go 360°
the opposite direction and makes the
completely OPP 360° would be the same
direction sorry
180 180° in the opposite direction he
spins around starts Moon walking spins
around spins around yeah because like
for me I remember like I remember the
the fear of disappointment was always
greater for me as a person than the fear
of like any kind of like oh I could get
like you know I could get like a slap or
something or like you know oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah to to to me the threat of like
let's say like violence um not that that
really ever happened in my household but
like the like I was always more scared
uh of disappointing my parents
expectations of me than I ever was like
I I think at some points I'd be like I I
I would prefer the I would prefer the uh
instant gratification of just being like
you know just just just come on come on
come on come on Mom just just just give
me a slap on the wrist please please
that's that's the instant gratification
please cuz like that's that's when I
knew for example that like my parents
were like actually like proper mad at me
is the moment when they wouldn't resort
to violence when they would they would
have what I what I like to call the
silent disappointment you know what I
mean like where like the quieter and
more like uh calmer tone that they speak
to me in signified to me immediately oh
I'm actually in like deep deep [__]
right now like they're so angry that
they can't even get angry at yeah my dad
had this uh thing that we called the
murder stair oh yeah cuz there's three
of us uh three three brothers so we we
all had we all knew and if he gave you
the stare you were done you done like it
was like Empress hockey just like like
oh you're like oh no you knew was going
to my dad hated that when we called he
hated that we called it that but it was
it felt like you about to be murdered it
felt it felt like that my my dad used to
threaten me with uh [__] it's so D I
don't know if I've talked about this on
the podcast when me and my sister were
really young I'm talking like less than
5 years old whenever we whenever because
it only works I don't think I remember
anything below the age of five okay this
is the one thing I remember uh because
he used to say it all the time whenever
we would like say something that like he
didn't agree with or like we would ask
too much from him my dad would say this
one thing which is don't make me take
you to the
bridge
what wait and that's all he had to say
for us to be like no not the bridge
because I don't know how it came up with
it but like in our dumb less than
5-year-old childhood brains we had
envisioned this like really scary bridge
where like if you cross it you die or
something or like if you cross it
something bad happens and my the most
Joey dad thing i' my dad I think
overheard me and my sister talking about
this we maybe sort in like a story book
or something I don't know what it was
maybe The Three Billy Goats gr or some
[__] you know um but like there was this
like Bridge we were like scared in and I
guess my dad overheard him he was like
perfect ammo
so now so then every time we were like
Dad can you buy us like blah blah blah
can you take us blah he was just like
don't make me take you to the bridge to
the [__] bridge and then we were like
I'm sorry don't don't take us to the
bridge I swear anything but the bridge
please spare us not the bridge your
dad's very uh opportunistic man oh my
dad was smart as [__] with that I'm
using that on my kid that's genius
that's genius the bridge that's genius
because it's such an O it's it's such an
open threat that doesn't resolve
anything because like or or doesn't
resort to anything because there is no
bridge but just saying you're going to
go to that bridge is the you need yeah
it's terrifying I still remember some
people call it trauma I I call it good
parenting dad's like I'm going to kill
you I'm going to punch you take to the
bridge I'll do
all Jesus don't be a little [__] oh my
God oh my Lord and look look who it
turned into I I became the man that my
dad wished for I I think the just the
one thing that my my parents I already
am glad they did is that they just
showed an interest in most things I was
doing even if they didn't give a [__]
really like but they would always show
interest and I think that's why maybe
then I was scared to disappoint them
because I knew they were genuinely
interested and so then if I did do bad
in school I'd go I'm telling them like I
didn't do good in this I'm sorry and
then they'd be like ah well no food
sorry no I'm kidding no
food uh no I think I think yeah just I'm
really grateful they should honey get
the ball in chain it's hard it's hard
cuz like showing interest in I think I
if a kid came to me was like man my
macaroni art was great I'll be like okay
I can do
better yeah I I don't I don't even know
what the okay I I like I I'm trying to
remember why I was like so scared of
like disappointing my parents cuz it
wasn't like they actually openly showed
any disappointment like if I got a bad
grade in School um you just knew that
they were they weren't proud or
something okay like here's the thing
right I I think this this is like one of
the things I I'm just like realizing
that as a core memory they're like we
don't care they told me we don't care
what grade you get as long as you knew
that you tried the hardest so every time
so every time I came in with a bad that
would work on every kid I don't know why
I don't know why that worked for me
though that that is an Asian parent
method if I've ever heard it my mom used
to say the exact same thing did they
that's the long con dude that's the long
it's the long con so every time I got a
bad grade in School they would just ask
me they just ask me did you try as hard
as you could have and I would just like
[__] panic and I'm just like I knew I
knew I cuz like I I knew when I didn't
try then I was disappointed in myself
and I think I I think what they like
five head taught me was that they would
they weren't the ones that were
disappointed in me I was the one that
was disappointed in myself for not
achieving my full potential and I'm just
like that's [__] five it's that it's
that question of like we're not mad but
are you satisfied
didn't think so and that's what started
the grind set baby yeah that's how you
get into the grind set yeah um so like
my parents did a lot of things right I
think um they you know some things I'm I
hope to learn from them and some things
I you know you know would Le in their
generation see I think that method as
well though of like that making you
realize whether you're satisfied with it
or whether you're disappointed in the
results that you made is not only a
really good thing to like teach or
instill into kid kids while they're
still in school but also like it's just
great for like building up this like
self motivation mindset as an adult you
know because like you wake up in the
morning and you're just constantly on
that idea like you know it's a
double-edged sword right like you'll
obviously always have that like hunger
to like strive for better but there's
also that double-edge swort of you're
never going to be satisfied with the way
you currently are in life right so it's
it's difficult like teetering on like
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing some for some people that's a
really good thing like you know for like
people like us for instance who we
obviously without us being motivated to
do it work isn't going to be done money
isn't going to be made yeah but you know
for someone who's working at like an
office job that's not really a mindset
that works this episode is sponsored by
boxu boxu delivers the experience of
tasting authentic Japanese snacks
candies and teas sourced directly from
centuries old small family businesses
right to your door their mission is to
empower Japan traditional snack makers
by sharing their authentic foods and
stories with the world this month we
have the first snack box you will
actually receive which is the seasons of
Japan snack box this is kind of like a
best of the boxu snacks if you will
following the season in Japan every
single month you will receive a themed
box what you got here Conor I have the
SBE this is a SBE rice cracker that
boasts uniquely irresistible tart and
sweet flavor combination of um Japanese
Plum and Zam which is like a coarse
granulated sugar so this is kind of like
a sweet and sour samb oh my God I
actually like these a lot I used to eat
these when I was little that's good I'm
going to pick out one of my favorites
which is I have this every time but it's
the white strawberries so what they do
is they just take a strawberry and
Infuse it with chocolate and it's in all
of their Seasons of Japan uh boxus and I
have this every time this box gets sent
to me pop it in your mouth can't it's so
creamy and smooth that's what I love
about it and of course boxu comes with
its own tea pairing every single box
this one right here is the organic Gema
which is kind of like a roasted green
tea really really good with a lot of
sweet things like all of the sweet
things you will find in your box Su so
if you want to be as sweet as us guys
just click that link in the description
to get your own box today and use code
trash for $15 off your first box Su
order back to the episode this is going
to be a weird question
but at which points in your lives did
you realize your parents were human
beings
uh what do you mean
that okay I was going to throw it out to
see if anyone get got the vi very
openend question I what you're saying
cuz you you see your parents as like
infallible growing up I I remember I I
thought like they were super humans and
then yeah you feel like they they they
know everything they brought you into
this world they they can they they they
take you out of this they figure they
provide they do everything so like to
you they're like they are like Gods
almost right they are like they control
everything you do yeah uh and then you
get to like 18 and then your parents
says something that isn't right and then
you can just Google it and you find out
it's wrong and you're like huh for me it
was probably when I realized that
although my parents really heavily
pressured me to go to university mhm
they didn't go to university themselves
that was probably the moment where I'm
just like oh is that why you guys want
me to go because like you guys didn't or
you know and that's the moment when I
realized I was like oh I'm doing
something that my parents couldn't even
do and that made me realize like oh [__]
like my parents aren't perfect you know
they look perfect they act perfect
around me but they're just like everyone
else yeah so that's probably the moment
for me what about you
that's wait why why did them not go to
university make you realize that because
I thought they were just like perfect
like the the way they because the way
perfect the way they LED their life was
just like you know all the right things
happened they you know they got to like
all the necessary stops and but that
also that that also like humbled me at
the same time being like Oh I can be
just as happy as my parents without
necessarily going down that route and
that kind of made me look at them as
humans in kind of a Different Light yeah
you know I I think there was a moment
where like I kind of like drifted away
from my parents for like like during
like the UN happens
when that generally happens when you're
like late teens yeah like late teens
early adulthood you want to find
yourself yeah yeah you're trying to I'm
trying to find you know I was trying to
find myself and I remember having this
conversation with my mom like like a bit
after that period where you know me and
my mom like I I I used to be like the
biggest [__] M's boy of all time of
course I was and then afterwards I kind
of like did the 180 and I'm just like
actually I'm an individual I don't need
to talk to my mom at all my mom I've
left that part of my life behind me I
remember having this conversation and
then I remember having a conversation
with my mom and then she just started
talking about some of her like
insecurities and I just remember like
thinking huh that's a that's a that's a
human
trait that's not that's not a mom trait
you're this you're this Beacon of
Happiness what are you talking about
insecurities my mom's always happy she's
always behind the motherboard there is a
beating heart I just it just like hit me
like a ton of bricks like oh my mom is a
human being with insecurities like me
and she's with her feelings yeah and
then and then that was like that that
started a path to me kind of like
getting real close to my mom and my
parents again and I'm like real happy
that like me realizing my parents were
just like human beings who were very
much infallable and had insecurities
like me I was like oh I get along with
them way better than I ever did as a kid
because it's like totally different now
but some some people you know some
parents go through their entire lives
never opening up that side of themselves
to their children and so like I think
you were put in a very rare position
where well I don't know if it's rare
would you say it's more common than not
I think your parents to eventually do
that with their kids I mean it really
depends I think I don't think it happens
as often as it should yeah um I don't
think it's as widespread um as it should
be yeah
because it's there's there's and it's
always a fine balance between seeing
your parent as like a parent you know uh
versus seeing them as just another
person like yourself who maybe one day
we're going to be parents as well and
our kids are going to look at us the
same ways and I'm I'm just wondering you
know was there ever a point uh I I I
should probably ask this to my own
parents was there ever a point where you
were like scared I would I would as a
kid sus out the facade you know be like
wait a minute my parents are just people
they aren't super humans they aren't
Gods it's just you know you just load up
that real life game of Among
Us like someone's someone's not right
here someone's someone's a little sus
right now I think maybe when you're a
parent you just have to play that role
for so long of being like this figure
that is so reliable sometimes you just
think that like you've been doing it for
so long that you have to be that right
like you have to you can't be this
person as emotions as she has yeah but
uh I think you know obviously I think a
lot of kids appreciate it especially
when they are older that you can talk to
them about yeah more personal things God
once this episode goes live I'm just
going to expect dad my dad's going to
kill me let's let's okay let's let's
Emil to Joey son I did not hit you as I
did not beat you as a child I dominated
you remember it I won't go away all
right let's let's start some beef right
now with our parents all right what no
I'm scared no no no no no this this this
this is the real this is the real
question you want me on death row okay
this is the real question we're in this
together guys all right here's the
question okay do you think you're more
like your dad or your mom oh I'm 100%
more like my mom you're more like M yeah
100% how so I'm just way more like her
I'm just I'm more chatty I share a lot
of traits with her I don't look like my
dad I look like my mom maybe I'm maybe I
look like the mail really CU I think I
think I'm more like my dad I think
you're more like your dad as do you know
okay are you the same way Joey because I
feel like when we were kids we might
have been more like our moms or at least
I I was like way more like my mom and my
mom was like yo he's going to grow up
and be just like me dude I looked like
my mom when I was little I I think I
actually have a photo of like me when I
was a can you go get my phone but like I
I don't know if this is just like a Hau
thing but like boys who are born Hau
like they grow up looking japanes as
[__] and then one day the Western jeans
are just like let me stop that for a
second
let me see let me show cuz like H I
think I have it on my phone anyway keep
talking while I find yeah like I like as
a kid I I always felt like I was going
to grow up to be like my mom and then As
I Grew Older I don't know when it
happened it was just such a subtle thing
but then I just started turning more and
more into my dad and I had this moment
where it was it was like a month ago or
something where I was just like uh it it
was in when we were in England and
Sydney was like you walk like your dad
and I was like what you mean I walk like
my dad and she's like I don't know just
your posture just that's when you know
it's game
over and and that's how that's when you
realize oh it's game over I've
officially transformed perfectly into my
dad now okay this is me when I was three
oh my God that's you do look way more
like your mom in that photo I look
Japanese as [__] right yeah what the
heck this is the same person M cut yeah
that's cuz I hated haircuts
oh yeah but like yeah no totally like I
think the moment when you start to I
think we talked about this in a previous
episode but like the moment when you
start to just without even thinking
imitate the exact same things you've
seen your dad do do you make the same
sounds as your dad oh 100%
like I'm trying to stop that whenever I
do anything that my parents do I'm like
I and I know I did it I'm like okay I
got to stop that dude like dude the
other day when when we were having the
Halloween uh party at our house I I
physically stopped myself from saying oh
[__] I'm shitfaced like I I had to
physically stop myself from doing that
cuz I'm like that's something my dad
would do it's very Charming when your
dad would do that yeah it is it's
Charming when my dad does it it's not
Charming when I do
it is fun so you reached the point where
you're like [__] I'm doing the things my
parents do uh I should stop that and
then I've come I've come to the point
where I'm like but it's just so natural
it just I'm I'm fighting against my
bloodline here I just I just need to do
it true I'm going to get to that point
probably in like my late 30s where I'm
just like you know what I'm I probably
won't even be drinking alcohol and I'll
be like oh [__] I'm shoot
face just tired it waiting for that
right moment to just bring that out
exactly yeah so but like I say now I'm
definitely more like my dad um you're
more like your dad I'm more like my dad
so you're the only one that's more like
your mom I guess so I wonder
why what about your brothers like are
they more like one of the parents more
like my dad all of them yeah I think so
yeah old the brother he's kind of half
half off as you say he has very
discernable traits from both right right
but I think it's because my job's
yapping my job's talking so not my mom
was the much more talkative one so I
think I you know I I my mom's always
very eager to talk and my dad will be
like he my my dad talks to but my my
dad's my dad he'll just be like how you
doing my dad
talks talk my my dad but my dad's from
the generation as well where he just can
like fix anything and build anything
cuz right now he's just remodeling the
whole house and he knows how to do most
of the stuff by himself and I'm like how
you how do you know this what what skill
tree did this how did you Speck into
this yeah like I I feel like I'm such a
useless man he's in the building for
sure yeah like I've got my drill bits
I'm just like what do I what can I use
them on huh oh nothing nothing nothing
in Japan okay it's being bred out of us
guys wake up they're trying to they're
trying to get it out of us man they're
not letting is use our tools it's not
DIY anymore man I want to DIY so bad I
just want to I just want to make a
shitty table is that how you know we
getting old I just want to it's a skill
I want to get better at like I feel like
it's like a RuneScape class that I've
been putting off for too long and I know
I got to do it I I recently found this
like YouTube channel of this Japanese
guy who uh creates like real life clay
sculptures of Pokémon that's sick but
like really [__] like amazing quality
and he like films all of his like uh you
know uh process in doing it and the
entire time just like [__] I wish I
could do that I want to build a table I
just see how it feels I want to I want
to build something without an
instruction manual yeah you know just
want ik ik doesn't count Amazon doesn't
count I just want to build something
with the raw materials and go all right
let's see what that just sounds like a
[__] video idea I think I think it's
cuz half half the the population uh that
was that was destined to be amazing
Builders have now become coffee experts
on Tik
Tok how did that Trend start
you see all the comments are like if if
Cy enthusiasts spent 1% of their brain
power on on advancing Humanity we'd be
flying by now we be I think we actually
have cured cancer if C the enthusiasts
have like had speced into the medical
field they'll create manyi black holes
to make to make the perfect espresso
pool so just activate your Gravitron
Cannon to allow the espresso to pour
evenly through the titanium
filter it is it is [__] how how in
intricate these these espresso things
are it's so [__] God damn I I saw the
one of like the evolution of the
different kind of like Contraptions that
they bu the one with the [__] they
like the thing the like thing that they
used to like spread out the Cofe just
spread out the like a Rolex mechanism
just to like spread it out perfectly oh
like the little ones with the little
hairs on it the hairs that just started
out as like a little like pine cone that
that was like 3D printed and then
companies made like advancements of that
and they got to the point where they
like had multiple gears just turning
around so you get the perfect spread I
love how the the the a lot of the
comments are always like that one coffee
friend who says that making coffee at
home is
cheaper that's me I'm becoming that
friend I just like my machine I just
like grinding it I don't like all this
[__] the moment we got to like temp
it down we got to start like [__]
fluffing it around putting in like
another filter I'm like this is too much
[__] to clean yeah I like my thing cuz
it's like a Lego thing I I make the
coffee it's like John Wick loading his
gun except I'm loading up the the milk
fro it's like three parts and they all
dishwash and when I'm done with my
coffee I just take them in the
dishwasher and I'm like this is easy
this is great I do the grinding and the
tamping down but like I don't go
anything beyond that grinding is great
like actually like the the one thing I I
would say that changed my coffee game
and made coffee taste so much better is
just grinding beans yeah it's so easy to
do and it makes coffee taste so much
better and fun great way to wake up in
the morning too dude the smell
uh but I I'm not going down this maybe I
will maybe have a long 5 years from now
like when when you stop the YouTube
grind and you're like [__] I have half
an hour in the morning or an hour or
however long it takes to make some of
these coffees cuz I swear I watch some
of these Tik toks uh once he stops the
YouTube grind he's going to start the
coffee gr no I no no no no I got to I
got to do something El I think some of
these coffee makers could go on to like
the end of one piece by the time they
finish making their espresso man like I
don't know how many steps they put into
that but it is insane uh but they seem
happy hey if they're satisfied there are
two types of coffee drinkers people who
just want the caffeine intake and just
some the people some people who want to
discover a new dimension yeah of coffee
making is there anyone who still drinks
I don't know I've inant coffee instant
coffee oh yeah I know we just we're just
we're
rich we don't
drink that was the most roundabout way
of saying we privileged right we don't
we privileged n of us drink instant
coffee
G yeah we're not we're not uh can we go
back to instant
coffee I can't I can't it tastes
horrible yeah it's bad I mean it is
because like like I think at least
around where I live there is there is a
lot of like roasies like like local ones
that have really cheap beans that if you
just buy a really shitty grinder and you
wanted to do like a French press or
filter it yourself it's it's like as
cheap as getting the the Giant that's
that's why I like asked just because it
seems like it seems like it's been
cheaper and cheaper to get like good
coffee you know even like even very
cheap coffee places have pretty decent
coffee at least in Europe you know at
least dude I bought I bought like a I
bought like a massive bag of coffee
beans the other day from Costco which
would probably set me back like if I
drink one cup a day it probably maybe
like a month and a half two months worth
it's like 1,500 Yen and it tastes really
[__] good I think people just care a
lot more about coffee now than they did
10 years ago we also like are aware of
how to make coffee taste better the Tik
toks the Tik Tok the Tik Tok yes well
okay it's it's the Tik talkers and the
hipsters that have like you know we we
clown on hipsters a lot but they've
changed so much about what has become
readily available like do you remember I
don't know when this started to happen
but do you remember when when did
hipsters start start to become the trend
setters I mean they've always been the
point they've always been the trend
setters and when then we've clowned on
them and then we're like wait a minute
actually this thing kind did you see
that um talking about hips did you see
that one Tik Tok of that guy who's an LA
guy in California in New York he's like
so like what's the deal with New Yorkers
man like I I went to you know in
California in La if I asked for a
scooped Bagel gluten-free there's no
problem they're like yeah thank you I
asked for it in New York and he said I'm
not [__] doing
that in New York I just walked in and
asked for a St gluten-free Bagel guy
just looks at me he goes I'm not
scooping your [__] bagel bro it's
like dude that's how I wanted it's like
get the [__] out of here with that [__]
I was like all right have you heard what
A scooped Bagel is no oh my God this
pissed me off what the [__] is it a
scooped Bagel is where you get the bagel
and you scoop out the bread so what you
just left with the outside of it the
shell why exactly why wait what do you
fill in that scoop because obviously the
bagel you'd normally put like you'd kind
of you know squeeze it like pce of the
idea is that you can remove some of
carbs and calories and still get like
the sensation of eating a a bagel how
about you just not eat a bagel yeah and
I think a lot of the internet reacted to
very viscerally and were like what the
[__] how I I would kick you out people
were like you're lucky you didn't get
killed in New York
C bang an insult to Brad I feel like you
shouldn't be committ don't be committed
to the bread train if you're going to
ask them to throw away half of it I just
I what do they do with that bread
presumably throw it away or maybe maybe
compost it or give it to someone or feed
it to animal I don't know something
Bakers all over the world are [__]
frothing at the M right
now I feel like it's just a hate crime
yeah against bread makers yeah that's so
rude just if you don't want to eat carbs
stop [__] eating bag throwing away
the crust on a
pizza I mean I mean not looking at
anyone in particular I mean I don't I
don't have a horse in this race guys piz
scooped can I get my pizza scooped
please can't imag going to like a a eal
place and being like hey remove all of
the hard work yeah go [__] yourself
remove the thing that's in the name of
your store but the guy like seemed I
think it was the the guy seemed so upset
that the guy was very angry that he
didn't want to do this and I think
that's what kind of made people like
yeah entitled to this man to ruin his
bread yeah um I mean like I'm trying to
think what other Trends have like popped
up recently that wasn't there when when
I was like there growing up like I
remember everything
yeah on Tik Tok I thought like craft
beer was a fad at first craft beer
didn't exist when when I was it just
didn't exist yeah and then like I
remember I think it was very hard to
brew beer at home but obviously the
technology has gotten so much better to
brew it at home than obviously canning
you think the coffee makes for
that yeah yeah I mean yeah you can you
know you can also like can be a now that
is something that is accessible and you
can do that on a very small scale
whereas canning canning stuff before was
like a very very expensive thing and you
did these giant machines to do and and
so that's why like still in a lot of
places they when you do like craft beer
it's um what is it [__] it's um either
Cask or it's in bottles normally no
actually no bottling is very expensive
as well what am I saying there's a
different way you would score it I know
cat basically yeah I'm going off them
one there yeah yeah cuz like I'm I'm
trying to think about what is like it is
basically the hipsters that have started
a lot of these trends that you know get
passion about something I certainly
thought craia was a fad when it so first
side popping up and then I don't know if
something just changed my brain to be
like actually tastes pretty good just to
not have a [__] Budweiser or sah with
everything people just get bored of
having the same goddamn beer cuz like
beer drinkers you know for a long time
it was kind of like you had like three
options yeah whenever you went to your
local place so it's kind of nice having
like a rotating selection of stuff but
also sad when you get a really nice
craft beer and it's gone I'm like yeah
yeah it's always just like takes time
right and it's like like who knows 3
years from now I might come up some
being like wait you get your bagels UNS
scooped the [__] is wrong with you you
know what was uh I went to twitchcon uh
last week and um in Vegas I nowhere does
draft beer it's all bottled and I was
really yeah I it was like barely
anywhere I I i' I think there's only one
place I could find it that had draft
beer but nowhere else had draft beer and
I just I like beer a lot so I'm always
like hey what do you have on what do you
have on tap cuz I'd much rather have
something that I maybe wouldn't drink
from a draft than something from a
bottle that I would drink cuzz I'm like
I just want to it normally tastes way
better but nowhere had it no like it's
called a faucet
actually yeah Americans just don't that
beer game is just so bad yeah the beer
game is awful what did you drink what I
drink I normally just would get bottled
beer like like rebottled beer no bottled
beer they pour out of the cake and then
they just is that a California thing
yeah can you scoop you drink 5 years the
beer out please can I get my beer
scooped can you shake the carbonation
out please I like my beer uncarbonated I
mean a lot of the drink drinks of bad so
I was like I'll just take a bottled beer
of I don't know an IPA or Goose Island
or something they had that everywhere so
I had that oh silence that's yeah it's
okay better than a Budweiser what do you
guys think of uh lacroy or Selter water
I like it I uh hated it at first and
then the hipsters got me [__] knew it
same thing with um like when I told you
guys I was like guys you should try this
whiteclaw thing if you want to drink
same thing with whiteclaw I was like
what the hell is this [__] I don't want
to drink it end of our La trip I was
obsessed well it's cuz you can just kind
of you can go to a party and like if you
if you have to drink or you feel obliged
to drink which you know obviously
shouldn't have to got want to the
progression for me was crazy with
whiteclaw like it started with like what
the [__] is this like cell alcohol cell
this is [__] now I'm at that point
where I go to a friend's party and I'm
just I judge them on what flavors they
have it's definitely going to take off
and so you only have the lemon the [__]
is wrong with you it's going to catch on
here I'm surprised there hasn't already
caught on here there's so many low
calorie alcohol options here we need to
get in on that train that's a milli I'm
sad that he hasn't caught on in the UK
yet the UK is still on in that phase of
like clowning on white claw cuz you
can't even get it at like every
Supermarket it's only at like some
select supermarkets and every time I've
been caught drinking a white Chaw in the
UK I get beat
up everyone's like you changed wow wow
this is cuz we have such good cider and
such good beer and it's like man I why
why would you want to drink that but I I
get it get it's perfect for a country
like here though like 100% ja Jaan would
love it so many sparkling water DRS they
already have like hya and stuff like
that right like we're almost there hoto
is just that's just juice that's just
juice with a tiny bit of alcohol at it
just to make you feel Hasbro is my first
alcohol well it's called horo right
which is like buzz not even Buzz it's
like I feel a bit warm yeah yeah right
it's like yeah
okay my body temperature went up oh yeah
so obviously I went to Vegas and I went
to twitchcon yeah how was that uh I
heard a lot of talks what talks did you
hear tell me the tales I've just seen I
just saw a bunch of Articles of like
what was happening you know during that
time what was happened uh just a whole
slew of things to too many things in
fact I understand this is a dig
or you hear like clueless it's not a dig
I was just like I just saw a lot of like
things that were picked up by articles
said that
like some tea happen man give me give me
the tea it's twitchcon of course te I
don't know the specifics though but I
don't know let's hear from the guy who
actually went there was there uh I don't
I mean I was at my booth the whole time
so I didn't hear anything right so yeah
I had a booth and it was kind of a
disaster really well no full story so I
I was going to do this this video well
this stream where it's going to be like
uh human crane game so someone could get
in the claw right and then I'd be like
the host and we'd be streaming it we'd
have all different types of games and
we'd be using the claw in all different
types of ways and there be prizes and
stuff that people could win it going to
be really fun sure so uh we we booked
this space that was like 30 by 40 square
feet which is pretty big yeah um like 10
by 12 meters something like that uh I
don't know what it is in meters 40 in in
uh meters um so yeah and then uh we I
had a production team working on it and
um we were we were trying to get
sponsors for it and we had like one
sponsor who was down uh par shout out to
them sick uh and then um we were gonna
get more but it was really tough like
sponsors just didn't want to sponsor
anything twitchcon um and it wasn't just
because it was like ballpit physical
related it was just cuz like a lot of
sponsors didn't want to be a part of
twitchcon right um for whatever reason
um and it was really tough and then I
was like okay well I'm going to lose
money but that's fine because I think
it's a really cool idea sure but then
the cost started getting like really
really really like crazy and got to the
point where I would have lost like $200
plus th000 GE which is like so n in
Vegas yeah so I threw it all in Vegas
basically I put it all on red anyway um
and so I was like okay well I can't do
this anymore I got to pull the plug
problem is I'd already like paid for
certain things like the booth space I
had to lock down MH and that was I'd
already paid for that um and uh I also
wanted to do I also paid had to pay for
some of the creative stuff that we'd
already done so I was already down quite
a lot of money and then I had this space
that had nothing to do with and I was
like well I should I should do something
with it because I feel like I'm going to
twitchcon anyway it would be really sad
if there's just an empty square and I
didn't do anything with it and I was
like okay well the only thing I can
think of that is literally zero staff or
like one staff member um or two at most
is just I'll just do our slpl but in
real life like I'll just have three
white walls and you can come draw on it
uh because I thought okay how it can't
be that expensive to build [__] three
walls um turns out it is [__]
expensive to build three walls at a
convention um there's just so much like
dumbass fees in these convention Halls
that they make you as an exhibitor sign
up to as we found out with Anime Expo um
but as I found out even more so with
this con um like you know when you when
you have the booth we didn't need a
floor for any of it it's just it's just
three walls m but they you have to pay
for carpet to be put down okay and it's
like $10,000 for a carpet to be put down
it's it's [__] yeah it's like what
what is this [__] like gold ass
plated carpet what is this why is it
$10,000 it's cuz it's like union labor
and pers Persian carpet it's ridiculous
it's so ridiculous so like there's so
many weird fees and so ended up building
three White Walls still cost me like 60
Grand which is c three walls which is
crazy but I was like yeah it's insane uh
and I was like [__] it let's just do it
because I I want to do something and I
don't care if I end up losing even more
money on this now because I'm already so
much money in the whole [__] it I may as
well just get something out of it yeah
this got the same energy as like
gamblers gamblers I'm already this that
also
happened I was like [__] it let's do
this uh let's [__] build it like
let's just I'll have something cool that
I at least can walk away from and be
like I have something I can stream I
have some kind of content and the
initial sponsor par was still down to on
this so I was like okay let's let's do
this then um and so that was really I
was really grateful they did that cuz I
helped kind of fund that and pay a bit
of those costs
so uh yeah we ended up we were like [__]
it let's do it and it was going to be
like a a a so you're going to need
visuals now Mudan sorry it was going to
be a square but remove one of the walls
so you can enter through that wall and
there'll be three walls boom boom boom
right and it would have been really cool
obviously on the outside there's only
one way to come in but I I didn't care
about that I was like [__] it like it'll
be cool just have three like walls
surrounding you and it'll look great on
the YouTube thumbnail it be really cool
um and then so I sent off that design
and they were like cool cool yeah we'll
get that built so the day before
twitchcon I go to the con which is all
also by the way there's a [__]
nightmare getting my badge at this Con
they should do what ax did I ACC I'm
giving credit to ax but they mail out
the badges beforehand yeah yeah dude it
it was like 4 hours for me to get my
badge because everyone was useless
nobody could help me apparently my badge
had already been printed which didn't
make make any sense and then everyone
just kept telling me to go to someone
else it was just such a mess it was so
bad I've by far the worst badge pickup
experience of any con I've ever had in
my life uh please fix that next time
short please it's like Partners right
you're not printing off that many
partner badges why can't you mail them
you know all the the addresses of the
partners because they have to put the
address down for twitch anyway why can't
you just mail these badges off and just
have them there this feels like a
no-brainer uh and avoiding like a bunch
of people and like fan meetups at the
like there no brain anyway so I go to
the con the day before and I go to I'm
trying to find my booth I don't know
where it is so I'm looking around for
like what is a very wh looking booth and
I see like this thing and I'm I'm I see
like the what I think is my booth so I
asked this guy cuz there's a few white
panels on the floor but nothing's been
built yet uh and I asked the guy I'm
like hey uh is it the is this the sea do
Booth he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
like oh cool cool I was like you're
building like a like a square right
without one wall he's like no I was like
what are you building he's like I'm
building a plus I was like a plus what
do you mean you building a plus I was
like I never [__] signed off on a
plus the [__] is this cuz I'm thinking I
only have one camera to timelapse this
yeah how the [__] am I going to like all
four walls of the plus how many a
timelapse all that sry spat um so I'm
like Jesus Christ I'm like what the [__]
so I call up my I'm like hey what the
[__] happening why are they building a
PL and so apparently what ended up
happening was the middleman we were
using uh just completely didn't forward
the design and then they just ended up
going with just one they made up okay
and I was like this is crazy so they
started building this there's nothing we
could do cuz they didn't have any of the
materials now to build what we needed to
build so I'm sitting there day one I get
there I'm already down 100 plusk on this
this idea and then I get there and they
can't even build a [__] square a
blank square and I'm like holy [__] this
is cursed like this is meant to be the
biggest failure of all time like why is
this going so wrong like I'm being like
I'm being punished for no damn reason at
least the blackjack tables will go great
for me tonight I
hope I'm being I'm being [__] in every
way and so it was just it was I was so
annoyed like that Thursday I was
miserable cuz I was like this is just
going to suck like this like none of
this has gone right like I'm down so
much money with not even three blank
walls to show for it I got a [__]
blank plus to show for it a blank who's
going to who the [__] wants that wait so
the blank plus is that like is it only
one side of the wall could be drawn or
could both it would have been two sides
so you would have two two sides were
branding for the merch and two sides
were white so I asked them I was like
what kind uh what can we do with the
materials we have what other the shapes
can we do cuz I want as much of this
wall and less branding yeah cuz I want
people to be able to draw I think that
was way cooler for people to be able to
do so we ended up kind of like if you
had the plus like this we kind of turned
it like this so that it was still secure
and then the so it's an X what yeah it's
an X like a really thin X it's a very
very very thin X that was still stable
stable but had way more room to draw on
um and so you couldn't see any of The
Branding so I I I must have I don't know
how much I paid for those prints to be
branded but I had to just scrap it
because I was like [__] it I want the
wall to be the focus um and it was yeah
it was really it was really hard because
I was just like God damn it like I've
sunk so much time and money into this
for it all to go horribly wrong even
when I was like trying to get something
out of it um it felt like I was being
punished for something I'm sure I'll
find out what this is this sounds like
the most engineering problem I've ever
had in my life it's just likea okay I
see you've uh sent the schematics for a
square with a with a side it's crazy
it's crazy we can do this this is this
is simple there is no possible way you
can [__] this there's no way you can
[__] that up it's so hard to [__] up
building a square I think I could have
built the square give me the materials
in half a day I think I could have done
it you should have just gone to the
hardware store just bought some drywalls
done it yourself so you know it ended up
happening and I was really kind of
bummed out cuz I was like [__] this is
just going to go wrong and then um that
night uh uh we got lwi and and then
we're like let's go just you know in
Vegas let's go and gamble by the way I
I've been very harsh on gambling I think
that you should never gamble unless
you're within the means to be able to do
it and you should only be losing
whatever you feel comfortable doing it
and I was I had I had a I had an amount
of dollars that I had in cash from
previously visiting Vegas and I was like
I'm only going to use this and if I lose
this I'm done like I'm not I'm not
withdrawing any money U luckily I didn't
do that at all Vegas but the first night
went horribly I just kept losing and I
was like this [__] sucks like I'm
just losing money and everything's going
wrong this is awful and so that day I
was like well at least I'll get 8 hours
of sleep and then I went to bed and I
couldn't sleep so I got three hours of
sleep that night and then had to go like
a Mr Bean episode everything went wrong
and then I I was miserable and so I had
to start the stream the next day and um
I start the stream uh and my backpack
just doesn't work and I'm like this is
[__] hu what have I done did I run
over an orphan at some point I don't
recall this ever happening what did I do
to deserve this like I feel like
something is [__] with me um and so
luckily uh gunrun uh a good friend of
mine was was an owner of
vjo the CEO I asked him for tech support
I was like hey can you help me and so
luckily it was an hour late and I did
people were the Conor already open the
plan was to start the stream before the
con opened kind of show off the wall and
then as people slowly come in I could
kind of do it but there was just a crowd
of people waiting and I was like no no
run the [__] wall I got to start the
stream I got to show the blank wall we
can't ask people like to stop cuz people
would just start walking in pick up a
pen and every's like no um and so an
hour an hour after the con opened I
finally got [__] stream working it
was a really fun stream but it was
really tough cuz the lighting was so bad
in the venue you could really see the
drawings very well um so the first day I
streamed for like 4 hours it was really
fun and and the wall itself was a great
idea I think it worked really well it
would have worked better if my initial
concept was there because that would
have been a lot more fun and I could
have kept track of it a lot more cuz I
to keep bouncing between the sides um
but it went really well and it was it
was it was a lot of fun I think people
really enjoyed it worked out in the end
it kind of well your definition of
worked out would have to take into
everything into account but I think for
the thing itself the idea was solid like
I think it was really fun um the only
thing we had to keep keep doing the day
one people wrote their names a lot
people were very uncreative people would
just write things yeah because they
wanted to do something and they would
put their they'd put their twitch name
and be like damn that's not bad and then
I'd come in and be like what the [__] is
this no one no one gives a [__] and so I
would just rub it out um no self-promo
yeah well it was cuz people were just
writing and there was not a lot of
artwork happening so what we ended up
doing was every day we were going to do
different types of like materi materials
given but we realized it was just there
wasn't that many drawings that we we
kind of just wanted to like just keep
rubbing out and getting rid of the text
Dick did you get not that many about to
ask same question you think a lot of
people were very worried and I knew that
I I knew that it wasn't going to be that
bad like I knew people weren't going to
behave you should have just done like a
thing where when someone came up with
the pen you should have just been like
no text well so we did end up writing a
sign saying no only artwork yeah just
draw something yeah and people did start
doing it and especially when I think it
was
because initial early on I didn't stop
people from doing it and then when
people see text they feel more
comfortable writing text but if they saw
only artwork I think people would be way
more hesitant about just writing
something absolutely um and so I think
if I was to do it again I would and I
think I'd like to do it again CU I think
it was a fun idea obviously I don't need
as big of a space so I think I'd be up
for doing something like that again I
think at at something like twitchcon it
kind of works CU there's a lot of a lot
of streamers came by and wrote stuff
which was really fun like I think the
idea was really solid I just needed to
clean up the execution and obviously
have the cost be way less yeah um and I
have an actual and I have an actual have
an actual box and have a square we could
have had half the space and utilized it
so much better and I I would have saved
I could I think I could have done that
booth for like 50k had easily have
gotten like one sponsor in a little bit
and that could have covered all of like
the the costs I would have incurred from
doing it and I think then it would have
been a great success and I think I
definitely would be down for doing
something like this again at twitchcon
um because I think it it was really fun
when it was working really well um the
signal wasn't the best so day two I
ended up swapping I ended up begging gun
I was like Hey gun do you have that
because gun gunun has this phone setup
for live streaming where you can just
stream shra off the phone oh [__] and
it's it's really good because in low
lighting the traditional streamer setup
is really bad but the phone the Samsung
Galaxy phone is so good and it and it
looked so much better um and so day two
and three we had a phone it looked a lot
better but I signed up to do this this
dumbass twitch rival thing which I
shouldn't have signed up for where it
was basically a uh Apex Legends uh uh
like tornament you lost me right but
imagine this imagine this right imagine
say less so they have like they have
like the two two Team captains for the
5v5 basketball competition they got
LeBron James on one team and they got
Jimmy Kimmel on the other team and
that's basically how it was and and
except except in in it's a battle royale
and there's there's n there's like 12
teams all different basketball pros and
then me and so it was awful I didn't get
to play I literally didn't get to play
for four hours I had to sit there and
stream it it was so bad um and the
rivals team are very nice and one of one
of them did apologize to me was like ah
sorry about that was a bit of a wash I
was like ah don't worry about it it's
fine it happens I was very annoyed at
the time though I was like [__] I
shouldn't have done this this I knew
this was going to happen cuz I'm not
good at the game and they made me a
captain and I was like no don't do this
put me with some Pro
please um so that ended up happening and
then I I didn't get to stream the booth
as much day two but day three it really
came together and we had some amazing
artwork in the end and I got to do
really fun twitch Rivals with Pete that
and demaise and five up that was really
fun we got to do like party animal some
physical challenges it was a really fun
TW twitch Rivals event actually that was
much much better than the other one I
think cuz it was all just like people
who were just streamers who weren't good
at any of these things in particular who
just kind of tried to do it and we want
we the party animals oh nice yeah Pete
popped off even though he never played
it party animals it's kind of like uh do
you know Gang Beasts at all it's kind of
like one of those games where it's like
people just punching and it's all kind
of ragd doll physics and you have to
like hit each other off the stages okay
okay oh we got to play some Gang Beast
for that g so fun party an was better
gang that hell okay um and so yeah uh it
ended up it was it was pretty fun uh for
like the work stuff but I I had signed
up to do way too much because I did like
did the otk schooled thing saw that yeah
uh which I won congratulations genius I
there was a there was a dots moment when
we had to do dots and obviously I'm I'm
pretty good at dots it's like give me a
beer one of the questions one of the
questions and I felt personally attacked
by this they were like what is the best
country to get a hair transplant
in do you know the answer Wales no it's
turkey oh yeah right that's I was like
all right [__] now hit hit the hit the
it's was a it was hit turkey like dead
on oh hell yeah oh I like damn he
knew easy points easy points cuz you do
darts so much in Japan and in the UK so
I I love doing darts and it was great um
anyway it was fun but I signed up to do
way too much I was like from I was up
from 8 and I I would get back at 700 and
I'd immediately have to go for a dinner
or hang out with people or H you know
socialize cuz that's main thing you do a
little social butterfly you are well you
kind of have to that's the whole point
of going to the is like socializing so I
I had like a total of like 12 hours
sleep across like 3 days it was so bad I
was dying I think if I would to do it
again I would sign up to like half the
amount of stuff I did uh it was really
fun con I think it was a great time but
man it's dangerous being in
Vegas so much gambling cuz there was the
hotel that all the streamers were in
yeah and you would just you would just
walk down the hotel and just walk past
the tables cuz they were right next to
where everyone was walking right so any
people who are staying in this hotel
could probably see all of their favorite
streamers just gambling yeah you would
walk down always there would be a group
of streamers GA of course there are
course you're in Vegas so yeah it was it
was interesting also Vegas sucks so much
I spending four days in Vegas made me
realize how much I don't like Vegas um I
think two days in Vegas was Max is what
I would like to spend I was there for a
year bro yeah that's [__] I think like
accumulatively day one day one was kind
of like exciting you're like man we
could do anything yeah day two I was
like okay it's kind of fun I'm kind of
getting bored of gambling Satur Saturday
which should be the hype day I was like
okay I gambling again oh gambling again
but then everyone be like we gonna go to
the club I'm gonna watch Diplo I'm like
I don't [__] know who Diplo is so I
go to this club didn't know it was still
around and then so I go to this club and
and and I I'm on a list I don't know
what [__] list I'm on so I rock up to
the thing at 2 a.m. I'm like hey I'm on
the list they're like what list I'm like
I named some names the list I'm I named
some names they're like I need a table
number like [__] t table number I
don't know what that [__] is so I'm
calling L I'm like L can you can you
what the [__] am I on he's like I'll
just come get you so he comes out and
gets me I go in and I immediately like
walk into this club it's so loud
obviously it's a club I know it's loud
but like the floor is so sticky where
it's like I'm walking like this oh
you're you're giving me some core
memories now I'm far too sober cuz I've
had like three beers where I need to be
like eight nine beers in for this
environment and L's living his best life
he's dancing he's having a great time
and I'm like
to so I can't do it and it's 2 a.m. and
I don't want to commit I don't want to
get drunk it's 2 a.m. I'm I got I got to
be up in six hours like quick someone
give me a
moly I got PP a Moly Moly right now I'm
like I'm I I sit around for 30 minutes
say hi to some people I'm like all guys
I'm going to bed like Okay and like this
story has just reminded me of like about
why I stopped going clubbing this story
reminded me of why I don't ever go to
clubs I just man I I hate the whole this
whole like of um this kind of dance that
happens when you're trying to get into a
club and I'm sure if you've ever tried
to get into a club you know it where
everyone's like who who's on a list
who's uh who who's uh Who's down
hierarchy you know you're just like am I
am I can I feel self-indulgent today can
I feel self important am part of Co kids
of coid you know why I don't miss
dealing with bouncers oh [__] I hate
bouncers man they're such dicks and I
just don't care for it I like if they
want to be like if they want to be a
[__] I'm like all right well I'm just
going to go they just power tripping
right yeah I'm like these guys this is
the like one moment where they get to
feel like like the Arbiter of who is
cool or not I'm like I don't care the
dunge master I'd rather just go home and
just watch League of Legends I don't I
don't [__] I don't care enough about
doing this dude this [__] this so
lame so yeah I did that and then the
next day it was like this razor DOL and
gabana party and uh what yeah it was
just in a club it was so [__] and so
we we it sounds pretentious as far yeah
absolutely so we get into this club and
I'm on some list I don't know what list
I'm on you're always get some list I'm
always on a list for these streamer
things right cuz I hopefully some good
list well I you know what ends up
happening is that you i' I realized this
after going to La a bunch after you
reach like a certain level of clout you
can just be like ask someone you're like
hey can I be on the list and they'll put
you on the list that just sounds like La
in general yeah but like I remember that
like I if I wanted to do this prior I'd
have to like if I wanted to hang out
with people I'd have to really like i'
feel like a burden asking but now I was
like I was like okay I'll just can I
like do you want to come to this party I
was like I don't know can you just put
me down and I just if I feel like it
I'll turn off yeah and so I was on a
list or whatever but then I ended up
going in with someone else who was on a
on the list which just I hate all this
[__] I hate this so much by the way
capital T the list and so we do this
like John Wick escort mission where we
go up up like up the club through the
back doors through like the the
workers's entrance kitchen yeah through
the down in the elevator below the club
through the kitchen right here three
elevators three elevators to get to this
club one down through the go and pass a
bunch of laundry workers go up again
through the kitchen go up one final club
we get in the special area of the club
which is just behind the DJ right and so
and I remember cuz I was with uh we got
in it was like me lwig uh germa and RT
games and we were all there and we all
get in and and uh
it's just it's so it's so [__] we get to
this club and you feel like you're in a
zoo because everyone gets to see who's
in the zone who's in the VIP area behind
the DJ right yeah because and everyone's
kind of like elevated and you're just
kind of on this Podium behind the DJ and
I hate this so much cuz I'm like I don't
want people cuz people just this is
people that people do this and I think
that like I feel like your existence is
so sad if this is what you must do they
stand at like the entrance to the VIP
and they're just like looking at people
waiting for someone to like let them in
right and I guess at some point like the
bouncer like left so people were just
walking in and so there were like people
who are like fans of the streamers
started interact it started get really
weird um and there was not there was no
drinks that were available to people in
the VIP you to like you to like uh go to
the bar bring it back and it was just a
whole slog I couldn't be bothered that
sounds like the worst VIP section I've
ever heard well yeah but it was
sponsored so I thought it would be like
free drinks for like the you know
because you want the streamers to show
up anyway so but anyway uh I I have a
drink I'm sitting there talking to
talking to germa and then at one point
during this one song this this is like
we've been in the club for 30 minutes by
the way right now and I I hate this
already I don't like this CU it's just
too loud you can't talk to anyone I
don't I don't hate this and um this
[__] massive cannon goes off like a a
I don't know what it is like a cold
Cannon I don't know what these things
are at clubs they don't tell me do you
know what these AR K do you go to clubs
this is this cannon that shoots out
smoke not smoke like cold air yeah yeah
I know you know and it's so loud the one
that that that comes in like during the
drop like put the [__] hands up boom
yeah and it shoots cold air all over
this section and it is impeccably loud
it is like thunderous it is so
impressively loud that it it literally
like shocks me and a few other people
I'm with we like what the [__] and like
so loud that you're like covering your
ears CU it's just it's [__] yeah and
so I'm like I'm like I don't like this
and he's and they're all like yeah we
hate this I'm like should we just go
this [__] sucks and we're like yeah
let's just go so we just leave right
away after 30 minutes um and I feel like
man I spent 30 minutes getting in and I
just hated it and I was like I'm just
going to leave right away that just oh
my God that just sounds like that just
sounds like the Clapping experience it
was pretty [__] I just don't think I
enjoy clubs remotely suck man I just I
think there's never an occasion where I
get excited to go to one no no no the
the only times clubs are good in my
opinion is when you don't plan for the
nights is when you get when it can be
like kind of a fun little offbeat thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah I actually think the
last time I went clubbing was with you
Conor Which club would we go to huh
which club did we go to I can't it was
like some Club in you're never sober
enough to remember going no that's the
point that's that's well that's all
anytime the club is fun yeah that's
that's it's it's it's one where you like
get a bit too Tipsy with your matze and
you're like I know this sounds like a
horrible idea because we're all [__]
drunk
but clubbing clubbing always starts with
the pretense of someone just saying [__]
it the problem is that the clubs get
like way too busy at a certain point and
that's when even when I'm drunk I don't
really enjoy it CU I'm kind of like
there's no space to like even if I
wanted to dance I can't really dance cuz
I'm shoulder to shoulder with someone
and I man I don't know if it's the
pandemic that did that to me I just
don't want to be in that situation ever
now flat out like I can be completely
drunk and I just don't want to be there
so I'm like I just don't ever want to be
in a situation where I feel like I'm not
in control of my own space yeah um and
so that was what all the clubs were like
because everyone in like twitchcon was
trying to get into these damn clubs uh I
I just yeah didn't wasn't much of a fan
of it yeah I do not regret not going to
twitchcon I thought that would be like
the kind of like Vibe and experience um
but that was like Saturday and Sunday I
mean the most fun nights when we just
got to hang out and just maybe maybe the
gambling the vibe that I like like
hanging out and chilling and talking and
I it's going to make me sound so old but
just not being in super loud places I
dig it I did not [__] with it like for
me every time I've been clubbing it's
always it's always a sense of it's too
loud to talk to people but what I want
to do is talk to people yeah cuz uh
unless I'm really really [__] drunk I
ain't going to want to dance i' rather
just hang out at someone's house flat
out like like just House parties are
goed House parties are goed chill yeah I
love it yeah not a fan of not a fan of
that so I don't think I'll ever I think
I just got to stop admitting CU I kept
trying to go to the club being like
maybe I'll maybe I'll like it but I just
don't I just don't like it I hate it and
the thing is it's it's not even just a
normal Club it's a club in [__] Vegas
dude you know how much like a bottle
costs it was like it was like
$1,500 what insane insane numbers I
could be blackout drunk and I wouldn't
pay that you couldn't there's no way you
could get me to
par um insane amount insane amount for
an alcoholic beverage yeah um I because
you couldn't I think you could order
separate drinks you had to go to the bar
but if you wanted to bring the alcohol
to the table and have them like make
drinks for you it was like yeah that
much no that's not including the tip
either oh no that's not that's not it's
expensive Jesus chist so overall the
whole experience out of 10 TR con the
com itself
was there wasn't a lot to do it's kind
of hard to give it there's so many
aspects of it where I would write
differently like one issue I have with
the con itself as twitchcon is that
because they need so many sponsors for
it to be profitable it it's just like
one big ADH and I feel like it's
literally just ads man discovers
capitalism I know but like you like I I
like ax I feel like they have like
there's a lot of really almost all of
the the brands feel in like like they
belong at an Anime Expo like I have a
ton of crit we all have tons of
criticism oh so this one just kind of
felt like they're all shoehorned Chevron
AT&T the military it's just like a bunch
of non the military yeah my booth was
opposite the Navy Booth they were really
chill they were super shout out to the
Navy they gave us tools to to use on our
booth because otherwise we would have
had to pay to borrow them from the union
labor oh my god um and the the Navy was
super chill and they came up some of
them came up to me like hey I love your
stuff you want you want to like hang out
with us we got like a booth over there
so I I I almost signed up I was
I was like I'm British I can't I can't I
can't no they were super chill they were
really nice actually uh they were a good
Bunch um I I think that they had some
space where they like had like they had
this whole giant area where it was just
PC setups where you could just play
games or stream and I think it's a cool
idea but I think why they have so many
streamers why do you not have some space
that you can go to streamers and be like
hey is there something cool thing you
want to try and like a booth you want to
make at twitchcon that we could make
that we can advertise and use that as a
poll like I think it's missing so much
like just Creator involvement outside of
meet and greets because and shows they
have they have some shows which are
great and twitch Rivals which which are
great but it's nothing the the viewers
can get involved with and I think that
doing a meet and greet is so they have
so much room for meet and greets and I
think that a meet and greet from a fan
perspective is the worst like the worst
way that you can spend your time to meet
a Creator because you line up for an
hour maybe 30 minutes if you're lucky
you meet your creator uh and and if
they're a big Creator you probably will
get 20 30 seconds to talk to them yeah
and I feel like that's not a good
experience like you don't get a lot out
of that as a viewer and also the Creator
cannot get to meaningfully have a
conversation with you whereas I think if
you do a booth that's more interactive
and the whole thing is that you're going
to be there all day you're streaming you
maybe you're doing something cool you
can have more meaningful interactions
with viewers in a way that I think is
way more fulfilling and also way more
way better from the Creator side um
because you're not just you're not just
going through this Mill of viewers just
saying Hi how are you how's twitchcon
picture hi have a nice day you know you
I think there's a way better way of
utilizing the space at twitchcon to kind
of allow creators to make creative
things I mean that's what I was trying
to do but the problem is is that with
from a creative standpoint I don't have
the money that Chevron has to blow like
Dorito's had like a double my space they
can just burn money cuz they're Doritos
I can't like I can't compete with that
like but it feels like twitch should
kind of be like hey we have the space
are there any creators that want to use
this to kind of do something cool and I
think that that's just such a no-brainer
from their perspective because it's not
like Anime Expo where anime is the
product in these anime companies because
they're coming up and they're doing
these things it makes a lot of sense but
like streamers are your product why are
you not giving them a space to show off
why are you not allowing them to kind of
show off some creativity and like have a
presence there where they can also then
have maybe uh you know the people from
Chevron will go and talk to them and be
like hey let's let's work together you
know we see your booth it's cool like it
feels like twitch con just is not
utilizing streamers at all like it feels
like they're not thinking about how they
can use some of the space cuz they had
plenty there's a ton of space being
wasted at that con I think the thing is
I like I don't even know what happens at
twitch con I think if there was more
streamers who had booths who were
streaming or doing these cool events you
would you would see more stuff I mean
for for me my always my public
perception of twitch gone is just like
oh this is like party weekend for
streamers but they get to gather in one
building and yeah my idea for it was oh
this is just VidCon for streamers yeah
yeah yeah basically basically just that
right it's kind of like yeah I mean
basically yeah but I mean VidCon
vidcon's for like 8y olds yeah VidCon
also sucks I think think twitchcon
twitchcon has something and I I really
don't want them to keep doing what
they're doing cuz I feel like people are
just going to get bored M cuz there's no
there's nothing to do at that con
there's not a lot to do like no
interactivity whatsoever there's like a
few things you can do the artist alley
is way too small you could you could
double the size of the artist alley CU I
think that's the that's the Highlight
for a lot of people seeing all these
cool things that likeit from Independent
Artists that they can purchase um and I
just think there wasn't like enough
interactivity for people to do things
they had a cool arcade section which was
nice but again that's like a small
little thing I think you have a product
that is streamers them a space to do
something yeah um you know I think it
also kind of sucks from my perspective
where I'm trying to do something cool at
twitchcon and I have to pay an arm on
the leg uh and to be fair twitchcon did
give me a little bit of a discount but
it's like was not enough it's a you know
and they they did what they could but if
there was like some kind of framework
they could do where they could kind of
give out these spaces and have some kind
of pre-built thing that was you know I
think there's a lot there's something
that they could H they could do that
would really incentivize streamers to to
to get involved and also it would be way
easier for Brands to get involved with
those streamers there because that's a
win for everyone yeah I I I think I
think it's it's it's feels like a
no-brainer but I don't know why they're
not doing it I think there's more
conventions in general need to do that
as well like not just twitchcon you know
like get get them more involved and get
people who are going to them more
involved so that there's actually a
reason to go other than oh I met my
favorite content creator for 30 seconds
yeah I just feel like cons really aren't
General going in the right direction for
that kind of longevity yeah yeah I mean
it yeah there's a lot of cons I've heard
that are really fun to go to I know that
John always talks about magfest and that
kind of stuff but being a great fire oh
dude the South Africa con I went to was
one of the best cons I've went to just
cuz there was so much cool [__] to do
there but like not a lot of cons and in
fact most cons 90% of cons I've been to
just don't have that yeah you know yeah
just feels like such a waste especially
the only thing you have as twitch is the
streamer yeah give them let them do
something
from who want to more
Crea that's the thing though I feel not
everybody on Twitch has that mentality
that you have right like a lot of them
just kind of want to lay low and just
like the meet and greet is all they can
do or all they can hand yeah I think the
meat and greets are great but they had
such a massive area for it and I was
like you don't need this much space
right uh well it's just a statement
right I think on twitch's part they just
like look what we [__] got you know
yeah yeah and I think there there was a
lot of meet and greets but again yeah I
think that like you can do which is why
I think we started doing more shows as
opposed to doing meet and greets cuz in
trash taste we felt that like a show is
a better experience for a viewer um than
a 30C meet and greet come to our show
come watch us live have this enclosed
experience with other fans where it's
great energy and you get a show yeah
like that's I think that's so much
better than doing a meet and greet
because a lot of the time the meet and
greet like I said you get 20 seconds to
interact with your streamer and that or
your content creator and that's it yeah
unfortunately a show takes a lot of
effort and energy and planning and uh
but the end result is always million
times more the the thing is is that it's
easy to like I think yeah there are lot
CR that don't want to do that but there
are just as many creators that if you
give them the option they will go for it
and they'll try and be creative they'll
try and push it they'll try and do
things but without the option it's never
going to happen and right now the money
just it's far too expensive to do
anything at at something like a
twitchcon as I've learned that I I I
would it would be very hard for for for
me who is like one of the biggest
biggest streamers on Twitch to justify
doing anything so it's like okay well
this ruls out like 99.9% of streamers
doing anything ever at twitchcon like
this is you know yeah feels like a shame
that's some improvement that they can
like hopefully hopefully hopefully
hopefully uh maybe I'll go to Twitch G
next year who knows I'm notp genin
streamer come on I need you all right I
need the genin did have a booth actually
I know you could have been there G I got
invited to their twitch Rivals I'm I'm
going toilet but yeah I was what I was
actually invited to go on the genin
rivals what we number one genin streamer
You' been up for anything
nope yeah the only thing Joey's been up
to is
shaving yeah I had to I had to shave
because uh I had a Halloween party last
week uh we invited a couple of my
friends we do it every year at our house
obviously we uh cosplay or you know
costumes or whatever like you know we
Shaggy and Scooby-Doo this year so yeah
so a had the fullon onesie and I fully
committed to the Shaggy bit I shaved
everything except for the goate here it
was [__] disgusting I look like if
Fred Durst had a baby with the lead
singer a Smashmouth it it looked [__]
gross was it worth it yeah fun time yeah
it was really fun um yeah it's always
good fun um I don't know what happened
in Shia I heard the I heard they I
didn't see the massive signs though I
went saying [__] off yeah they're saying
like we will do some bad things if you
do bad things yeah they should be a did
this gigabrain move where they were like
we're gonna tell people that they can't
drink alcohol but there's no punishment
if they drink alcohol and then they
started boarding up stations uh to stop
people from meeting up but it just made
it people it made it more congested yeah
so it made it more dangerous yeah which
is the most Japanese move I've ever seen
in my life they're like let's fix a
problem oh we just made it worse I think
there just like there's just such a
disconnect uh between like all the
people in Japan and the Japanese
government and like just allowing
younger people to express themselves and
like I I don't I think getting drunk and
and all crazy in uh in Tokyo is not not
great or the best way to do it but I
feel like just clamping down on it and
trying to get rid of it entirely is not
the move here no um you know and I I
think yeah obviously there was some
there was some bad apples in it but I
think generally it all went it all went
okay except people when they were trying
to flip cars over yeah but I don't I
don't think like evacuate all the trucks
get them out of here CU a lot of people
were saying that it was because of the
Korean um the
disaster but they they've been trying to
do this for years now they've been
trying toid it and this is the year
where they really try to do stuff but
this weird kind of rule where you can't
drink but they're not going to do
anything they'll just have a man come
around and Shout at you but he can't do
anything well we're actually filming
this on the 31st of October so it's
going to be interesting to see what
happens next couple hours I just it's
just dude I feel like they've just gone
about it the most Japanese way possible
and that is the worst possible I feel
like they could have done this in a few
better ways uh but like having no laws
passed and asking people not to drink is
just never going to work stop having fun
yeah there's no fun allowed in the city
and I've SP to am right I've SP to a lot
of foreign people who just seem to not
care which I think is just going to make
all this a lot of the foreign Japanese
relations that have been bad already
recently forign Japanese Rel just making
it even worse whenever I see the
Japanese uh News videos popping up and
they cuz they love Japanese news loves
doing this they love finding a foreigner
drinking alcohol around there and being
like look look at them not following the
rules we said that's the of the problem
and all the comments are like wow you
Auto translate Japanese like wow classic
foreigners can't follow rules here and
it's like Jesus Christ like no we can
follow rules we follow rules that make
sense to follow you know yeah and I also
think that just having a news crew only
show some foreign people who when it's
not it's [__] just foreign people who
are doing this Japanese people are also
doing this never mind the fact that
those four Dudes who flipped the truck
last year were all Japanese they were
all Japanese so it's such [__] they
do this and it's very frustrating
sometimes that that because they know
that this does well and it gets
engagement on the on the Japanese news
sites if they if they purposely blame
Fring at the mouth so frustrating cuz
then you when when these these cases
that come along earlier like the ones
that where the actual Foreigner is a
piece of [__] yeah it it makes them feel
like they are right yeah for this this
Prejudice they have yeah yeah oh it's
frustrating we'll see we'll see what
happens in the next couple of hours Shia
might be Mega quiet or or they could be
about going I think it's going to be bad
I think it's going to be because they
they've bought it off way too much and
it's they've made Shia station actually
uh like more dangerous to get around
there cuz they barded off as if it
wasn't already [__] dang it's so bad
yeah I don't know why they're so it's
such a such a dumb idea what they did
yeah is it is it just me oh has like
even has the want to come to visit Japan
just like increased as like in the past
few years like what you think is the
Catalyst for that because I felt like
there was interest before a little
podcast called trash I do I I I
genuinely think that like what what
we're doing and a bunch of other Tik
toks and all stuff just showing Japan
off all the time has helped has has made
it so much more it's all a free
advertisement of Japan by foreigners who
come to you cannot go five minutes on
Tik Tok without getting recommended a
Japanese food video it's not possible
it's not possible do you think it's
because we're in Japan so we getting
recommend cuz I can never tell because
it's so it's so hard to tell because
like have you ever like logged into
YouTube with a completely fresh account
or like incognito mode and you're like I
do not recognize any of these people and
they have like 26 million views I would
I would say we probably are getting
recommended the more cuz we are inclined
to watch that but a lot of these Tik
toks have 2 to 5 million views and that
can't just be the xat population R
that's more than the X
yeah and it's weird cuz like um I did I
made some shorts just for YouTube and I
did one where I um there was this this a
store called onigiri Bongo I don't know
if you heard of it this this onigiri
place where people line up 5 hours for
oh yes I have heard it's [__]
ridiculous people up to 5 hours it's
normally a 2 hour wait um and uh I found
out when I was looking at the website
that you could just call up uh obviously
if to do in Japanese but you could call
up and just say like oh y yaku deimar
you could reserve uh a SP in the line no
no you could doaku masar oh hi saw this
and then you just say like tomorrow
11:00 a.m. can I have this and they're
like yeah so I yeah I just saw on the
website it said that you could call up
and Reserve to go and I was thinking
well oniri is probably the most to go
food of all time you don't sit down for
it is a it is a strictly tog go food so
I was like oh okay well easy so I I was
like there's no way it's this easy so I
call up I say hey can I come pick it up
tomorrow at at 11:00 and they were like
yeah so I order it I go in and I felt I
felt like I was doing something wrong I
like there's this long
line like look at this for in a c no
dude so there's a line of like 60 people
right right all Japanese yeah uh and I
go up and I'm like I don't know where to
go cuz i' my first time coming here I'm
looking around I'm like I think I just
go right to the front yeah and uh as I'm
going in this guy goes uh and I was like
oh m k i and he's like oh oh like a guy
in the line was going to like tell me
that I was cutting and so cuz I saw
someone else just do it right as I was
about to do it so I was like oh okay go
up I just say my name they give me my
rice balls and I was like oh [__] that
took 10 seconds I've hacked the system
yeah and I was like why why is everyone
waiting 5 hours in L so I made the CH
being like this is [__] people waiting 5
hours and you can just do an advance
because that kind of information is not
available on Yahoo that's true that's
true but then which is what they but
then I started getting these comments
from people who are like classic [__]
foreign tourist doesn't want to wait in
line makes the Japanese people wait
longer and I was like no they're doing
it to them [__] themselves I was like
what the [__] bro these people do these
comments know Japanese people love line
love waiting it's like a [__] Pas
time for them I thought the British
loved a queue but man the James and so
yeah I got like a bunch of weird ones
where they were like uh uh there's just
a bunch of people who are these very uh
weird people who are I guess obsessed
with Japan Who come out of the woodwork
occasionally and just want to slant on
you for doing anything even remotely
differently meanwhile you look into them
and it's like Nigel from Arkansas who's
never left his country before and just
read a lot of [__] about Japan I'm like
stop you know a lot of people you know
my my Japanese is not fluid at all I'm
like baby conversation level but you're
a bit better than oh I appreciate that
but the amount of doors that open up
that I realized that when one I wasn't
afraid of talking on the phone and sound
like an idiot and being able to like
book things it opened up so many
doors being able to do that and
confidently like call them up cuz I'm
like this kind of conversation I'm
pretty sure I can handle yeah um cuz I
was like I'm going to ask can I reserve
they're going to say yes when I'm going
to tell them the time and they're going
to be like all right what do you want so
that's how it went yeah and I nailed it
and I went and got it and it was great
it was so delicious I wouldn't wait 5
hours but it is by far the best on a
Gear we ever had about oh really if I if
I was was a you like unloaded the secret
everyone's going to be fing up for
[__] res now there's going to be a
line for
reservations cuz I think they make it
either the morning off before they open
or like maybe later in the night but
either way it was amazing like it was
really good and it was these things are
[__] huge they're like twice the size
of normal oniri 83 and I was I was dying
it was so good a kilo of rice so yeah if
you if you do go you know and you got
like a day trip planned it's like set
seven or eight of you guys just go pick
up a bunch sweet great all right well
there you go there's a recommendation
for you guys and and uh we'll leave it
at that hey look at all these patrons
though shout out to those guys hey make
sure when you come to Japan be
respectful follow the rules and uh you
won't get a uh [__] NHK a Crim yeah
don't fil CRI can we just stop filming
our crimes in general like I I'm might
be the hottest take we've ever seen on
trash if you [__] around you find out
all right so don't do that I Le
especially like if you're going to film
crimes at least don't be cringe while
you're doing yeah you know what I mean
least be cool you know like don't make
we fil CRI cool crimes
but uh no don't do that but hey you know
what you can do is going over to
patreon.com trast support the show also
huge huge also you can go over to
Twitter to send us your memes uh
subreddit as well we have that and if
you hate our face listen to us on
Spotify and uh we will update you guys
on the uh Shia Halloween Fiasco probably
next episode all right see you guys or
not we'll see all right bye guys
bye
[Music]
he